ah oh hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to Anatomy
now Anatomy is a game that actually came
out a while ago but I never got around
to playing it I even heard about it a
long time ago as a very as a very you as
a very well made horror game in terms of
atmosphere and build up it is not a game
that just throws cheap jump scares it is
a game that is supposedly going to fill
me to the brimmy brim with dread and I
don't know if that's true or not I've
seen games that have claimed to do the
same yet fall woefully short but I can
say one thing for certain ACE dork why
is this so dork
good thing I've locked all the doors
inside my own house that's a funky hand
alright everything is locked
well good everything is locked oh also
my choice of art is a little peculiar I
do have to say that yes I know there's a
glowing thing but I'm just checking okay
good
it looks like a cassette player and a
cassette I got that up pretty violently
in the psychology of the modern
civilized human being that is difficult
to overstate the significance of the
house since as early as the Neolithic
era humankind has defined itself by its
buildings buildings for worship
buildings for socialising buildings for
protection even buildings for the
commemoration of the dead but of all
structures that mankind has invented for
itself there is little doubt that the
house is that which it relies upon most
completely all right to continued
survival I mean yeah there's a tape in
the dining room why would I know that
who would be telling me that why are my
eyes robotic why do I have the vision
quality of the VCR also where's the
dining room also what is the dining room
this is definitely not the dining room
whew I am so much faster than I thought
it was
Oh Oh Oh Lu this is the dining room I
see I should have tried that door but
alas I did not all right good
there is something strangely unsettling
about all this but I can't put my finger
upon it so it's like a subtle
expectation that something should have
happened by now the house is one of the
key elements that separates modern
humanity from its more primitive
antecedents no other creature goes to
such lengths to create lasting permanent
shadow for itself now regard said
shadows with such reverence and import
how do human beings of our modern age
faster this tremendous sympathy toward
their homes there are many reasons of
course but perhaps it is due in some
small part to seeing them as a
reflection of ourselves there's a
reflection of myself then I don't have
any care about what goes on inside of me
which is pretty apt yeah ooh in the
bathroom did it say oh why would there
be a tape in the bathroom okay the
anatomy of the house is such that
personality was less superficial than at
first it may seem you Nana me to carry
it further if we were to dissect the
helps as we might a human cadaver we
found ourselves able to isolate and
describe its various appendages and
their functions in a decidedly
anatomical fashion there was even a fair
member of direct comparisons to be drawn
between those organs of the house and
those of the human body
yeah I don't know about that one
[Music]
tell me what's the liver of the house
what's the gallbladder of the house I
want to know what the the eyes of the
house are I guess a security camera
system
is this to the garage where's the garage
ooh hi I don't like this this is quite
perturbing I'm just checking to make
sure there's no monstrosity x' that are
standing in the corner
although i guess me thinking that there
might be is is kind of lending credence
to this game big good about building it
up but alas it seems there is nothing
for example let us examine the living
room out in the permanent space at a
house as ground level as well as
typically the center of activity in a
well populated home the living room is
very much the heart of the house while a
human heart circulates blood to
oxygenate the body's extremities the
living room circulates people activity
communication it is the room most likely
to be found beating as active and
vivacious as its name would imply the
comparison was only strengthened when we
consider also that the living room is
most commonly the room to contain the
fireplace making it additionally a locus
of actual physical heat alright
interesting I feel like you're really
reaching for this one but I'm gonna go
to the living room to get a beating
heart going I'd like to think my nose
are the balconies of the house we're
gonna be a beating heart in here I don't
think that there's a let me clamber over
these I don't think there's a fireplace
in there doesn't seem to be much of a
locus for human activity going on in
here I often equate the pantry to the
ears of the human body here the food the
residual - think of the kitchen and
dining room at the stomach or digestive
system of the house though this
comparison is tenuous
a contrast the function in analog of a
bathroom should be immediately obvious
the highways and corridors of the house
are availing circulation coursing
throughout its frame a staircase bears
more than a passing resemblance both
physically and symbolically
to a spine yes the windows of a house
so if much the same purpose as eyes and
anyone who has ever rounded a bend or a
long drive and come suddenly face to
face with a tired dark manner will tell
you that it is difficult to shake the
impression that the house through its
loudness windows is a creature capable
of vision and intelligence I don't know
who you're polling for this a tape is on
the stairs why is it tape on the spine
oh it means the tape is in my spine I
just need to reach into my spine and
grab the tape hello I guess I haven't
gone upstairs yet I don't like it I
don't like it I don't like it I don't
like being up here maybe there's no
reason to be up here why would I be up
here I'm not allowed up here my parents
said I wasn't allowed upstairs during
special gift exchange time I gotta go
back to the toilet the bathroom was
perhaps the room that most eludes direct
comparison in this fashion
penis at a stretch and allowing for a
bit of poetic sympathy it might be said
that the bedroom is not unlike the human
mind where those parts of it which
dictate the thought and imagination the
penis from the bedroom dreams are
correct
passions are ignited Jesus epiphanies
are experienced and cold threat at early
hours penis and the bedroom is where
people invariably spend the majority of
their time don't compare
at last conscious penis I don't want to
go I don't want to go in the bedroom if
this game was the type of game that like
psycho analyzes you as you're playing it
there just be horrible penis monsters
ever they're everywhere if I ever went
to Silent Hill it'd just be big stomping
Pinay
marching they're worried towards me okay
where is this bedroom see the weird
thing is like I feel better going
upstairs now that I know that there's
something up here to get which is weird
right
that's gotta be weird it was like I
wasn't allowed to come up here before or
all these other rooms I thought it was
just a void I don't like it what is dad
all about who's staring at dad in the
middle of the night oh it's a kid oh I
thought it was like a Bill face okay
still that that's not pretty
oh no no this layout is a little bizarre
but okay it's like a Sims default house
that someone didn't have enough money to
fill it with furniture so they just
slammed it wherever they could this is
weirdly creepy for nothing happening
there's absolutely nothing happening so
why am i scared in any way shape or form
there's nothing happening absolutely
nothing there's nothing happening and
yet this analogy is an incomplete one
where obviously the mind is an
exceedingly complex thing but the
bedroom represents the thinking dreaming
part of the brain and it is the basement
that represents those and lower
unconscious parts
yes the basement is dark it is buried it
is a place full of cobwebs where
memories are stored yes point of
comparison
truly
often the unnerving uncertainty that
comes with considering the deeper
aspects of the human psyche is not
unlike gazing down at the swimming
blackness pooled at the bottom of the
basement stairwell it is a place we
spend our childhoods filling with
monsters that will lay for years a
station closer bearing some specific
errand we seldom ever want to go there
me and my brother used to me and my
brother used we used to go down to the
basement all the time that's where we
hung out we play hide-and-seek in the
unfinished part of the basement but you
know we had a basement you the basement
ooh I like it
I'm going for it I'm a big brave man is
it a finished basement or is it an
unfinished basement there's nothing
scarier than a Midwest unfinished
basement oh it's unfinished I hate it I
hate it oh it's big I hate it I hate
everything about it I hate it I hate it
and I hate you not you I love you but I
hate you
whoever's in this basement with me well
I think I see it all right weird how
it's just on the wall over here
well glad we got that out of the way now
I can get back safe and sound and
nothing's gonna take me provide nothing
nothing was gonna chase me from behind
absolutely nothing why would anything
happen but everyone knows that you leave
the basement as fast as possible so
nothing gets the chance you that's when
you learn to sprint up stairs that's
what you do there is no other way to go
up stairs
then at full sprint out of a baseball
of course this comparison though
appropriate is a very heavy-handed one
and after my basement is really more
than a storage space littered with the
corpses of spiders and woodlice they're
pirates and psychoanalysts no doubt
dread the thought of a dark basement in
truth it is the bedroom the waking mind
that place of Dreams they're actually
the most frightening of all why why oh
the master bedroom I didn't even realize
I wasn't in the master bedroom all right
find a whoosh all right going upstairs
on the second floor that you don't go
that full-speed you go that slow take it
nice and easy
where's the master bedroom food Oh weird
oh it is red in here red for the fiery
passion of my mind right okay well ooh
that's different what's oh oh I didn't
notice those two all there's no door oh
wait a minute wait wait wait wait wait
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute I don't know why these are
scaring me but wait each night we shut
our sensors to the world for hours at a
time trusting in the house to keep us
safe
until next we wake me when the state of
extreme variability we will spend
something like 20% of our lives anything
might stand beside us watch us keep us
company until dawn
we have never proceeded we can only pray
that the house will not let touch things
carry on as we sleep in this way during
those hours the bedroom seems less like
a mind and more like a mouth and lay the
perhaps is most likely to betray us yeah
but if he earnestly place ourselves most
at the house is mercy and spending each
night hoping that it will not bite down
and with the house weighed down why what
what was that
[Applause]
but wait okay wait no that can't be
[Music]
why sir why is it like this now why
would it be like this what is Oh
fascinating
yeah interesting don't know why I'm able
to do that don't know I've yeah take
that most purr-turbing Tori what the
hell is going Y is this so scary why why
is this
zip it the downstairs bathroom not the
downy bath no no no no no no no no no oh
downstairs bathroom I thought it meant
the basement bath I thought it meant
basement bath eat on wall this is absurd
that's just ridiculous you are out of
your mind
period full stop that's the end of my
story
[Applause]
okay good sure there is
add hahaha doors are unlocked what what
what what what what doors what doors
would be which doors would that be put
doors you talking about oh okay um how
about the front doors can I get up the
front door hmm hmm I don't like it hmm I
don't like it at all
I hate it I hate it in fact yeah I hate
it I hate it a lot I hate it a lot I a
lot of hate to this right now I'm gonna
skip the master bedroom I hate it Oh Oh
be bathi damphir tup be bathey time I
haven't been in this room
how's this bed rebuy room oh that's nice
range by fine so I'm kind of like
bedtime prayer I I would play that too
any time I needed to see that windows
little funny
that's a funny window yeah what a funny
window
what a strange funny window
what a funny window windows so funny hey
yeah that's fine yeah well oh oh it's
fine it's fine
hey look a tape yay yay yay ah what's in
the master bedroom I don't know what's
in here show me show me show me show me
yourself
whoo show yourself show yourself a
little lady
show yourself no one's here okay good I
didn't think there was anyone here why
that door no no wait what I don't like
any part of this I don't like anything
about what's happening here
everything that is happening is
happening poorly in my mind all right
but I got a tape so that's gotta count
first
yeah kind of gets in your skull a little
bit there's a tape in the living room Oh
is there is there a living room period
because at this point I'm not quite so
sure hello hi how are you doing oh good
the beating heart of the house and mmm
that hmm probably shouldn't have picked
that up probably infected me with some
kind of glitch I've seen corridor
digital I know what happens when you
touch a glitch what okay we're fine
thought I saw something then again I
imagine I'm gonna think I see a lot of
things when it comes to this game looked
away for one second I look away for one
second you get loud any eyes out here
you didn't even say what was happening
next you just got blasty why it's the
basement maybe no okay what do I do it
why I'm sorry I ignored you I just was
taking a gander around and see if
anything was gonna happen all right
so what now you didn't give me any
direction I'm just guessing that it's
gonna be in the master bedroom but you
know I've been wrong before
I'll probably be wrong again hello
oh that's weirdly bright oh um it's very
fine
unbelievably fine actually I've never
seen something finer to be honest anyway
got this one and this time I'll pay
attention
[Applause]
[Music]
and the path through the bedroom window
is a trap approaching the young man
steps out approaches delivers to the
front dollar his body is covered in
clips responsive court its walk into the
downstairs heaven blessed in Sierra
Leone spits on the carpet
he's moving to the first floor breeding
with exciting plans goes to the basement
and stands at the top of the stairs
an angulated Henderson is named the door
into the frost and I can feel this
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't get it why is this so creepy
this is so creepy I don't understand I
don't understand why God okay fine
this is so bizarre this is so bizarre so
weird I I swear I have not experienced a
horror game like this in all my life of
playing a Horgan now I've played
story-based horror games but this is
this is one where the story itself is
the most terrifying part of it and
nothing's really happened
oh oh that's peculiar oh whoa
get raped this is good stuff that's up
in painting oh this is great got any of
those ticks bursting everywhere oh well
I guess I didn't need to shower anyway
whoo Wow okay come on
Mamba humma hum bah bah humbug
yeah not unlike the human body I was
thinking the same Lou somebody who's one
too many cheat codes in the sims I was
thinking the same thing this is exactly
like the human body just a mishmash of
horrible horrible this anyway time to
tip tap down the spine Crick crack oh
that's a bit of a problem
Oh what oh that's oh I did I can't all
right then sure good good great good
felicity be still good Oh take this and
that and kaboom
hello gonna check the bathroom first
make sure there's nothing going on in
here hey how you doing all right I'll
see you around kid see you around
hey what happened to my fresh basement
open not yet but I bet it will
I can't sit anymore
[Applause]
great good stuff good stuff all right
good stuff good stuff good stuff great
stuff actually maybe even the best stuff
all right
am I just supposed to remember where
these things are I think I remember yeah
generally good thing I got such a
impeccable memory
[Applause]
you know oddly enough this is hurt never
mind I was about to say this is the
least creepy version of it because
everything is crazy so I'm like God just
expect craziness what hurts exactly
who's hurting what's what what what
what's what's hurting probably all this
noclipping happening I knew I shouldn't
have done to the glitch hi who's up here
hello how are you good to see you hi how
you doing
anyway anybody's seen a scene like a
cassette or something ah yeah thank you
take that okay
okay good I absorbed all of that if
everyone got it at home we'll be doing a
quiz in the comments so whatever the
question that was just asked right the
answer to it down the comments and I
will be grading if you get it wrong you
will be removed okay good good good
great great
remember
okay good what just happened oh oh ah
good if the doors I should have known
that the doors were the meat of the body
the the sphincters the doors are the
sphincters okay
I just go down the basement and I just
couldn't in the basement otally fine
there's probably nothing weird in this
basement probably the most normal place
in the house it's probably fine down
here where there's nothing cuz there's
been nothing in the game yet the whole
game so if there were to be something
you definitely wouldn't be down here
[Applause]
[Music]
oh all right okay hey there's no eyes on
that house I can't see me so
Oh sting interesting interesting with is
there like is there like another ending
have I even reached an ending I don't
even know I don't understand I'm sorry I
didn't mean to break the plates it just
was something that I could do I didn't
know that that was gonna make you mad
then knows gonna upset you I was trying
to force potential oh no where am I have
I been digested
that goes for too long and lived in is
it dream I don't know man
how's it without those creatures who
built that I knew it fester and so they
come up in a minute
that's usefulness no longer satisfies
them make no 11:7
and it's dolena and they fooled me why
wait door is open
shades drop always empty
okay if I could go I'll leave you to
your hunger it's so weird
oh no this is so bizarre this is such a
fascinating and horrifying tale why did
I wait so long to play this game do I do
anything I don't know well I managed to
close out let me go back in and see what
if anything is left to do and there
might not be anything left to do I don't
know but I guess
oh no it's here okay okay um I guess
that's it I don't know if there's more
than one ending the only thing that I
think I interacted with was breaking the
plates which that probably was a big
faux pas but is there like another way
to play the game if there is I want to
know but I'm not 100% sure this though
was incredible I have no idea how they
managed to make that so creepy you have
to play this for yourself like this is
nuts I can't be crazy right let me know
what you guys think of this down in the
comments below like there was just this
perpetual sense of dread that's built
and built how do they get away with that
who do they think they are either way
that was amazing there'll be a link to
this game in the description below I
believe it's like two three bucks
something like that well worth it that
was just like I said a completely
different experience from almost any
other horror game that I've played I've
played a horror games with great stories
that were scary I've never had a horror
game with just an absolutely horrifying
story
we're the entire experience was about
this horrifying tale and you scared
yourself the whole way because to be
perfectly honest that's what makes
horror great is dread
fearing what's around the next corner
and I did that so kudos to Anatomy
kudos to developer of anatomy amazing
loved it so thank you everybody so much
for watching if you want to check out
more scary games that I have played
there is a giant playlist right down
there in the description all you got to
do is click on it there's over 300 scary
games in there videos actually probably
more than that scare games and if you
want to see more videos that I upload in
the future hit subscribe ring the bell
to know when the videos are coming out
leave a like if you enjoyed the video
thank you so much for watching and as
always I will see you
[Music]
[Applause]